I'm a big advocate of of learning all
the rules and then only after learning
them then breaking them in large part I
used rules as guidelines because I think
they're there for a reason
breaking the rules is the only way the
personal style comes out and I like to
take liberty and the little things so
that I can still respect the rules that
are there to be able to look at my
garments and say okay wow this is fully
canvas this is hand-sewn wow this fabric
it's from this great mill out in England
or Italy I want them to be able to
recognize that and that's really what
breaking the rules allows you to do show
a little personality and whether that's
wearing our trousers a little shorter
our sleeves a little shorter or our tie
a little twisted and wonky and it's
really this filter that says the better
you dress the worse you can behave and
that's really at the heart I think of
what I'm trying to do and how I'm trying
to incorporate and consistently bring
back my boyhood into this you'd be
surprised how much you get away with
when you're wearing a tuxedo or when
you're wearing an amazing suit
[Music]